[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Hi,
I'm Maya Kaczorowski.
I'm here at KubeCon EU in
Copenhagen walking the floor.
And I'm here with Rani
Osnat from Aqua Security.
RANI OSNAT: Hello.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: How are you?
RANI OSNAT: Great.
Very busy.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Of course.
So tell me a little
about Aqua Security.
RANI OSNAT: So we provide full
lifecycle security solutions
for container and
cloud-native applications.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: What
does full lifecycle mean?
RANI OSNAT: Right, so we think
that containers change not just
how applications are
deployed, but also how
they are developed.
So you need to embed security
early on in the process.
So we start by integrating
through the CI/CD process
then through the registry
to deployment and runtime
and production.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Got it.
And this morning we had
a great announcement.
We announced Cloud Security
Command Center integration
so that Aqua Security can
write findings directly to that
and customers can see that
in a single pane of glass.
Tell me a little
bit more about that.
RANI OSNAT: Right.
So as security solutions,
we create all sorts
of events and alerts
that our customers need
to understand what's happening
in their environment,
their security posture,
compliance posture,
and so forth.
But customers seldom want yet
another dashboard to work with.
So they're looking for
something more centralized.
So by passing this
information, which
includes things like
vulnerability status,
runtime events in containers
that are misbehaving maybe,
or images that were prevented
from running because
of security policy, we
passed all those things.
In the Cloud Security Command
Center they can see all of that
in addition to other events
from GCP that they're--
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: They can
look at everything happening
in their environment at once.
That's great.
Can we get a demo?
RANI OSNAT: Of course.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Sounds good.
RANI OSNAT: Right here.
OK.
So we're looking at the Google
Cloud Security Command Center
list of findings.
And here under Aqua
Security we can
see that there are runtime
violations and vulnerability
violations, as well as image
assurance violations which
means that these are
images that were not
approved by the system.
Let's take a look at
a runtime violation.
And there are details
here that are fed by Aqua.
We can see that the action
here was detect, meaning
this wasn't actually blocked.
That depends on policy.
And if we look at more details
on how it looks on the Aqua
console, we can see information
about the exact nature
and paths of this violation.
Some environment variables.
Most importantly, we can
see in the audit screen
that this was actually
an action triggered
by a vulnerability
known as ShellShock
in which a user tried to
do a privilege escalation
and Aqua detected
that in this case.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Thanks so much for that.
That was great to see how
we detected runtime findings
and then saw them
directly in CSCC.
RANI OSNAT: Yes, it's
pretty cool, isn't it?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Thank
you so much for your time.
Are you having a great
time here at KubeCon?
RANI OSNAT: Yes, it's amazing.
A really amazing conference.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Hopefully
we'll see you again in Seattle.
RANI OSNAT: You will.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And thanks to
all those at home for watching.